join my gang Joe Rogan podcast by night
all day
but you have a responsibility of
greatness yeah there's there's very few
people that ever get to the position
that you not just were in when you won
the title when you were the youngest
ever UFC heavyweight or light
heavyweight champion not just that the
youngest ever UFC champion not not just
that there's the there's also
responsibility that comes with potential
it's not it's not just like what you've
done and you know it's what you could
have done right
you fought Alexander Gustafsson be
honest about that how much did you train
for that fight I trained I trained for
the fight but but I I definitely I had
this thing where I just felt invincible
and did a lot of wild stuff leading up
to the fight I definitely didn't give it
my all
as far as partying and sleeping Ryan
really partying drinking stand up on it
yeah yeah I mean when you win a fight
like that where you weren't 100% does
that sort of almost reinforce this idea
that you could do anything you want and
the man imagine if I trained next time
if it's someone big I'll train like yeah
so I have this I'm gonna share something
what I'm not sure if I've ever shared
this with anyone else before but I had
this crazy thing that I would do where I
would party one week before every fight
and I did it throughout my whole career
and and this was stupid but it was this
mental crutch that I had I literally
would one week before everybody I would
go out and I will get blacked-out wasted
and my logic was if this guy were to
beat me somehow um I I can look myself
in the mirror and say that well I lost
because I got hammered the week before
the fight so so it's a built-in safety
net there's a safety net yeah exactly
so I did it my whole career I would go
out and get hammered one week before
every fight have you ever worked with a
sports psychologist no but now but now I
don't my my ovince st. Preux fight was
the first fight that I did not do that
hey it was my worst performance so I
said I don't think it was your worst
performance I think you were very
unjustly criticized for that fight
because I think ovince st. Preux is a
very tough guy he's very difficult fire
is very strong he's got a brutal left
kick
he's athletic he moves well I believe it
was a good performance but it was my
worst performance
see I think ovince st. Preux is a really
tough guy it was a tough fight and you
hadn't fought in a long time not a lot
you were off for how long how many
months 16 months or something oh yes
that was over a year yeah there's a long
time over a year a lot of stuff going
yeah I mean you're fighting a guy who'd
been pretty active and fought some good
guys had a great victory of a Shogun and
looked real good in a lot of his fights
and wasn't up-and-comer the main thing
about ovince that really bothered me was
um he was he was the most well he was
seasoned he actually has been fighting
longer than I have no uh people don't
realize that but he was just so um green
and raw still like skill watch skill
wise like I don't um I study everybody
extensively and then I come up with
their patterns I figure out the way they
flinch I figure out their first
favourite punch their second favorite
punch the third their favorite
combinations the way their setups to the
takedowns when they clinch one side of
the head is going to be a literally
everything I know everything about every
opponent what side they're gonna shoot
whether it's gonna be a head inside his
head outside what am I gonna do about
that you know I figure out everything
why they shoot what area of the cage
they like to shoot everything um and
with ovince st. Preux
he doesn't know what he's gonna do he's
so unorthodox unorthodox um you know he
gets these random knockouts from these
weird angles and he's just wings
something he almost closes his eyes and
next thing you know he's knocked
somebody out you know so the scary thing
about him was uh he's so unpredictable
and so and I had a lot on the line um so
I just said you know what this guy is
he's in a shell pretty much the whole
fight he was defensive the whole fight
and I just thought I I closed through
the fight and not really risk anything
which I felt like I let myself down
because normally I was just I mean
normally when you get someone like that
you just you know take him out you know
you should actually just been able to
take him out but I was content with
winning and I think those I think that
was one of the first fights where I
actually just wanted to get the win
get my money go back to what my actual
goal which was DC instead of wanting to
finish this guy like normal so I had to
really question my I really questioned
myself and why um why I was like that
while I was considered with closed
[Music]